[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah rex ryan is here espn sunday nfl
countdown analyst former nfl coach and
he's going to take part in the amazing
race the 34th season of the amazing race
tonight at 10 eastern and pacific on cbs
also available to stream live and on
demand paramount plus we'll get to that
topic coming up here in a moment when
did you make the decision not to coach
anymore
uh dan that decision was made for me i
think
and you can tell i tell you what the
bills made a horrible decision obviously
clearly the best team in the nfl
but it is funny so life right now you
know shoot i haven't lost a game in five
years so uh
yeah i'm doing good but this is you know
i golf i live right on a golf course i
golf almost every day
um
i have a houseboat so i go to the lake
quite a bit so
i mean it's rough man there's no
question
any concerns about the bills
i got no concerns i dan i i think
i look at this team as like who the heck
is going to beat them
hey
that this might be one of those i mean
they could challenge the dolphins and
all that type of stuff you know and
obviously i think the bears are the best
team ever that year in 85 and they had
that one stumble against uh miami
this is this team has that kind of look
to it and the reason i say that is
there's so much depth
like that's the thing they have depth at
the the d-line spot
bill walsh used to tell me he goes you
got to win games in the fourth quarter
you have to be able to rush the passer
and remember back in those days
coach walsh was way ahead of everybody
else he kept like nine or ten active
defense alignment
just to do that he thought he'd be ahead
so he had to rush the pastor and uh
that's exactly what he did so
my dogs are barking over here but uh
but i see that team doing that they add
to von miller they
um who's a who could still play
and then offensively i mean hell this
team never punch i know you know they
don't punt you know you know so
it's uh
i i think actually the craziest thing is
i think their biggest test
will be at miami
and the reason i say that you've got to
play miami in september
um
at that stadium i think it's the biggest
home field advantage in the national
football league i've been on that
sideline i've been up by two touchdowns
in the fourth quarter and i've seen our
team wilt under that sun and i think
that's it it's not just the team they
got a hell of a football team they're
well coached obviously but
it and and the fans are good but it's
that heat and and i just think it's uh
i think it's a a huge advantage so we're
gonna find out
i also was curious that the browns
losing to the jets and then they have to
turn around and play the steelers
tomorrow night if you were coaching the
browns you were kevin stefanski
do you acknowledge what happened against
the jets or you clear the slate and say
let's just turn our attention to
pittsburgh
well i think you got to address it
because you you can't let something like
that happen again and it was
i mean the jets had a point one percent
chance of winning that game like look at
all the factors that went into it that
you lost that game and everybody's on
hey they should have told nick chubb or
whatever
at that time you're you know look you
can say it
but if you score a touchdown here's the
thing in a coach's mind you're thinking
well that's seven
it's not six points it's seven points
you're up two touchdowns whatever and i
get it the clock is but they had
they had to um
blow a coverage
clearly blew a coverage
and just give them a freebie they had to
the jets had to recover an on-site kick
and they go down and score again like
so many factors that went in all within
two minutes so
i don't blame chubb or or whatever i but
this is something yeah you have to
address it you've got to talk about
finishing games you've got to talk about
those things but yes 100 you're right
the best thing that happened to the
browns is that they they do
they talk about it and then they they go
immediately into
playing against pittsburgh and so i
think it's kind of an advantage to him
to play so early i really do
we're talking to rex ryan espn sunday
nfl countdown analyst and part of the
34th season of the amazing race which
we'll get to in a moment
can you be out coached or outplayed
like
one or the other
well you can get both
because i've been both
you've been
how are you out coached you're out
coached when
uh at big moments
that that team is more prepared than
your team is
and making mistakes we saw it we saw
baltimore get out coach which is rare
you got a john harbaugh coach football
team
and
and then the amazing thing is in that
game
i thought greg roman had all the
pressure in the world on him
and he came up with a phenomenal game
plan and it started with protecting his
quarterback and so he he i mean a plus
plus plus
and then on the other side it's like
you're the baltimore ravens don't ever
forget that when you got somebody up by
you're up 21 points i'm sorry
game set match if you're up seven points
the mentality always was game set match
and here you're up 21 you allow tyreek
hill to go blow and buy you whether
blown coverage or
you know whatever it was well that's on
you as a coach so that's getting out
coached
that's getting out coach you you handed
you gifted the miami dolphins a victory
right there but did you ever out coach
belichick
what's that did you ever out coach
belichick
we damn sure i played it
you know a couple of times
i don't think uh coach i think uh
maybe one time
maybe one time and and i i coached
against them
you know more than any other coach in
the history of this game
and
i'm sure he outcoached me and every
other one but i think i might have got
him once
maybe once what was that post game
handshake like when
you you felt like you out coached him or
did were there all the handshakes the
same with belichick
nah they were a little different and you
know what's funny i i mean i say i'll
coach my
i mean i i don't i don't know about that
i mean i'm not going to just go on
record as saying i'll coach them but
i think you just did i think you just
did right yeah maybe i did
but i knew damn well my team was
prepared against his ass every single
time and if i had tom brady i might out
coach him a few more times but
um but generally it was one of those
deals where
you know
i had a ton of respect for belichick and
and always have always will uh he was
clearly the best
best football coach i ever
you know had the opportunity to coach
against so it wasn't even close if you
had brady would you still be coaching
probably
yeah
yeah and you know what's funny
um
and obviously look i would have never
done as good a job as belichick did with
tom brady but i think he's proved that
he can go other places and still be tom
brady so
um
you know i i mean you have a once in a
lifetime player like that but the best
that that our game's ever seen i would
hope so you know i knew what one thing
i wasn't going to get out coach
defensively that against anybody that
ever coached i knew i could coach on uh
my team on defense could be there with
anybody that's ever done it and
whether it was a gift that that has been
passed down or i inherited or whatever
it was i knew i could coach defense now
the other part of the game
all that you know
i probably wasn't as good as belichick
obviously nobody has but i know i i
could coach him and
and
it came to me one time somebody said
well if you look at my years as a
defensive coordinator with baltimore
and my six years as a head coach of the
jets
all right
in all of those seasons so i guess
that's 10 years
the defense that i coached outranked
bill belichick's defense in total
defense nine out of those ten years so
i'll just go ahead and rest it on
would you rather draw up a defense for
mahomes or josh allen oh
that's why i'm in this chair right here
dan i mean i don't have to call it
defense against those guys
but if you did
yeah i think i really think
probably patrick mahomes and which is
like a ridiculous statement because he's
amazing but josh allen to me
i see the difference in the red zone
and
where josh allen almost appears to be
unstoppable in the red zone and why
because he can he can run through it
like a halfback
in the power of a fullback
he's got a bazooka for an r both these
kids do um you know but kansas city is
always about the shovel pass and all
that type of stuff you don't see mahomes
with that threat of running and running
through linebackers that you do with
josh allen and i think that kind of
separates them in the red zone in
particular but either one it's a
i mean that's a
that's a horrible okay like literally
you would sit back and go
man do i have the flu do i have the flu
somebody else need to coach this defense
this week you know if i had mike penn
and be like all right
you got this kid
uh explain to me how you got involved in
the amazing race
you know it's just one of those things
it was uh i gotten a call
from uh
somebody at cbs and they're like would
would you and your brother do it i'm
like
yeah that sounds great i love the show
amazing race
a great show
but i'm like my brother here's a problem
my brother's still coached so there's no
chance i'm doing it
and either way i'm playing golf one day
and
and uh i said yeah it was funny i got a
call you know cbs they see it you know
they just wanted to see if i was
interested and so
one of my buddies like look that's
that's you know my mom and and my
mother-in-law hold on that's their
favorite show i'm like yeah it's awesome
and he goes
man i would love to do it and so i'm
like well
let me call back and here's the thing
dan it wasn't like they said okay you're
definitely in 100
we had to do we had to go through
everything and believe me there's a lot
of stuff you go through
psychological evaluations several of
them
um there's a wonderlic test that you
take you get all the physicals once you
get down you gotta take all these shots
because you never know where you're
going you gotta it's it's a huge process
videos you're doing all kinds of stuff
and and so they never treated us any
different you know i mean it was a it
was a long process but when they chose
us it's like all right let's go man and
here's the problem when when we were
going through the process i was weighing
like close to 300 and i'm like
well let me just go out and run you know
i'm gonna go out run and you assume like
you know hey i'm a kid i used to run six
miles a day like
all right
i start going i'm like man oh man this
is rough i finally make it a mile i'm
like that's it there's a big hill i'm
like i'm i'm done
and
but after three weeks i started running
three and a half miles a day so i got my
weight down i lost 50 pounds and this is
like in about a month or a month and a
half so i go down 50 pounds i start
running three and a half miles a day so
i was like because i don't want to let
my my buddy down and my buddy's a uh pro
officer here in uh in the nashville area
he's um a former power lifting champion
and he runs
in marathons so i'm like
we are very similar that way power
lifter marathon runner
very similar that way but uh but it was
i'm like let's go for it so we did and
you know it's a hell of a show and it's
great and it's funny i would watch like
other seasons you know trying to get
ready
and i'm like oh hell i can't do that oh
i can't do that i can't do that you
can't do this like
i wouldn't exactly i think when you're
when you're old
slow
weak
and dyslexic on top of that
probably not the best teammate
you know but either way i mean it's it's
a blast and when you got there finally
started doing things it was great good
for you good could you beat belichick if
it was you against him in an amazing
race
if it was a fight maybe
you know i mean if we had that you know
a fist fight i could probably beat him
but i'm not beating him in anything else
he's
that dude
that guy's sharp is attacked there's no
way
great to talk to you have fun we look
forward to watching you thank you rex ah
my pleasure dan take care espn analyst
former coach rex ryan and it's season 34
of the amazing race